in terms of writing yeah a script let's
say it's like for a 90-minute feature
film what do you think's more
detrimental to a film story conflict
that takes too long to present itself or
conflict it starts off too soon well
interesting well I think you know
kontin you know what they teach you in
in film school or any writing book is
you know conflict is the source of all
drama if everybody if all your
characters are just getting along then
yeah nothing you know how long are you
gonna so I mean I think there's a
tendency there's a reason why most
movies over the last 20 years have
adopted the James Bond opening which is
just start with like start with conflict
from frame 1 so that you can hold
everybody's attention I don't that's a
good question I would probably say that
you know delaying conflicts too long or
not not introducing what the central
conflict is going to be can be a problem
like for example I did a film I did a
short recently it was like a 40-minute
short and shorts are harder because I
think you know because you have less
time to establish character and the
movie that I'm was making is this
thriller called where's Roman which I'm
actually very very happy about with it's
kind of a surrealistic thriller and the
the 3/4 of the movie is really this one
character venturing into this very
disturbingly weird hotel and meeting all
these characters and all these terrible
things happen too but I wanted you to
care about this character before all
this crazy happened so I
deliberately wrote a you know like a 5
is almost a five or six minute scene in
the bar where you meet this main
character through another character and
it virtually is no conflict it's really
just two guys who like a stranger
strangers meeting just having a
conversation about stuff and it was a
way of getting you to know who this guy
was and what a situation was and who he
was before all this stuff happened and I
think half the audience or the people
that watched it half for a little more
than half really appreciated that
and then I was rude I met another
filmmaker you know who's been around for
years and years years and said I really
loved the movie I would have cut down
that conversation at the beginning
meaning that he was saying you know get
to the get to the thing gets of the
conflict get to the conflict suit I
think that's the hardest thing for
writers to do is to try to establish a
character even through action and and at
the same time getting the plot going
which tends to be when the conflict is
is established so the only danger of
starting with conflict too soon is that
you've got to maintain somehow maintain
this level of drama and that if you stop
that people are gonna be accustomed to a
certain tension or a certain thing and
when you stop to smell the roses you're
going to may lose everybody but you know
I don't know that's that's that's what I
was thinking or like with dinner with
Andre right well that's you just that's
what it is but then you say look that's
what it's going to be and then conflict
takes different you know it doesn't have
to be there holding your daughter
hostage this guy is being you know
passive aggressive and that can be
enough you know that's true yeah in that
context you know that can be in you know
that can be the Death Star battle
depending on you know what you've told
them the viewer the movie is supposed to
be right so Bourne Identity vs exactly
you have different expectations of
conflict I think right so when you are
writing how are you weaving in conflict
like what what are you are you already
thinking of what those beats what those
points are going to be when you start it
or do you come along in your rewrites
yeah I think you know I've never been
really good at the whole like outlining
process although I have had to do that
when I've written for money because they
demand studio demands a very specific
detailed outline before they move you on
to the writing stage but personally I
like to try to get to know the character
in my own mind know the characters
enough in my own mind so that I know how
they're going to behave or react to
whatever I throw at them to me it's like
if you can understand
characters and and sometimes that's why
it's so easy or excuse me sometimes
that's why it's better to base a
character on somebody you know or
yourself because you know whether you
based on your brother or your mother or
the best friend or yourself because then
you know how that person talks how that
person is going to react to something
and then you don't have to make
everything up otherwise the burden of
you as a writer to make up everything
that happens is is a lot whereas if you
know who the character is and the
example always use if somebody's walking
down the street and a guy jumps out with
a knife and says give me your wallet if
it's if it's me as a character I
probably get on my hands and knees and
start crying and you know whatever if
it's Jason Bourne you know a fight chase
ensues you know what I mean so so
knowing the character first I think is
helpful and then yeah I think all
writers probably have there in their
mind a handful of not everything a
handful of things that are supposed to
happen they're going to drive the story
but I I prefer probably to my detriment
to only think out the whole thing to a
certain degree I try not to have
everything set and I tried it maybe I
have that I have certainly maybe the
first deck I know what the inciting
things are going to be but then I like
to sort of let the characters in some
way tell me what the next scene is as
opposed to making them do something that
I've already I think more interesting
things have come out of that and in the
times where I've had like a lot of us
have an ending in our mind at times
where I've had a definite ending like
the whole reason for writing the script
was because I got the last scene in my
head by the time I get there
neva tably it's not that because the
characters have grown and the situation
has taken on some sort of life of its
own so by the time it gets that thing it
doesn't make sense anymore they would
have been an imposed ending or an
artificial ending and so I think the
writing can be a lot easier the more
real those characters become for you
you